and as we told you a minute ago the
other thing that happened that was kind
of great that we're enjoying is that the
guy in charge of getting Democrats
elected to congress himself lost his
name is Sean Patrick Maloney he
represented the Hudson Valley he was
beaten by Mike LawLers now the
congressman elect and he joins us
tonight Congressman elect thanks so much
for coming on how'd you do this
thanks for having me Tucker well look
Democrats control everything in
Washington Albany and New York City for
the first time in our nation's history
and they have created an absolute mess a
41-year record high on inflation surging
crimes skyrocketing energy
costs and a poorest Southern border with
not only a massive inflow of illegal
immigration but drugs coming into our
communities killing 300 Americans a day
and voters in New York were fed up and
they had enough they wanted to restore
balance and common sense to every level
of government we've picked up four
congressional seats in New York and we
are going to have 11 of New York's 26
members as Republicans come January and
that is uh historic and I think in my
district especially you know Sean
Patrick Maloney was as chair of the D
Triple C sent a memo to State Democrats
back in January of this year demanding
that they gerrymander New York City
Congressional maps and knock Republicans
down to three seats well they did it and
then the courts intervened a
democrat-appointed court of appeals
throughout the maps called it
gerrymandered and unconstitutional and
appointed a special master and we got a
fair map and when I looked at the map I
knew I could win the seat 42 percent of
it is Rockland County where I'm born and
raised I've lived my entire life my
family has been here over a hundred
years we won Rocklin by 10 points and
that's why I defeated Sean Patrick
Maloney yesterday
it's just we're savoring the irony and
probably not enough victories to
celebrate but the ones that came through
or we're celebrating and this one is
especially amazing because this is the
guy in charge of getting Democrats
elected to congress do you think he saw
it coming
uh no not really because he was
gallivanting across the globe to Paris
and Geneva and London just a month ago
raising money for Nancy Pelosi and it
wasn't until about two weeks ago that he
realized he had a problem when he had a
call in Bill Clinton to come campaign he
asked Hillary Clinton to send an email
and not thirty thousand that she deleted
but he also asked Jill Biden to come in
and and do a fundraiser for her just
last week you know this District
this district is home to the clintons
and George Soros and uh the fact that
they now have a republican Congressman
speaks volumes uh to to where the
electorate is
it's pretty great it really is and we're
going to celebrate Congressman like Mike
Lawler of Rockland County New York thank
you so much
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight